voulant voir la loi monsieur votre fille
jouer l'armée c'est bon je suis pas mon
fils est au-dess us qui joue à laguna
seca ce fils kim aris kenya tuquoi la
liane là je m'en fou qu'est ce que tu
racontes gars m'en fou qu'est ce que tu
racontes là
alors arrête de nous faire chier et on
vient se mêler samara
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ton concert à bruxelles jeudi
dernier le chanteur en a profité pour
prendre la parole au sujet de l'épidémie
de coronavirus
mais surtout pour faire la morale aux
non vaccinés
discours applaudi dans la salle mais
vivement critiqué par certains
internautes sur les réseaux sociaux les
anti vax ils ont le droit les gens ont
le droit de douter du vaccin il ya un
doute alors et on peut en discuter mais
il ya un doute je ne peux par exemple
moi je les fais à mes à contrecoeur moi
j'aime et j'ai eu peur de le faire c'est
ça voilà donc les gens se posent des
questions les culpabiliser comme ça
ouais alors qu'ils chantent que c'est un
artiste dont la voix porte ça m'a gêné
il a le droit d'exprimer son avis ce
n'est que oui sont en fait ce que lui
reprochez annoncé qu'il n' y commence à
nous saouler alors quand c'était un peu
dans une boutade je pense qu'il a voilà
c'est pas très grave mais euh non c'est
nous les ondes c'est sûr que c'est pas
très grave mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui - vraiment je respecte les
gens mais bien s'ils veulent pas se
faire vacciner
a le droit de donner son avis à dire
voilà moi je me suis fait vacciner je
pense que c'est bien après engueuler les
gens les faire culpabiliser en tyrie
quand il dit il commence à me saouler
pour dire qu'en patrimoine dit il
commence à nous saouler vous lire entre
les lignes ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire en fait moi et c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit moi tout l'été quand je le faisais
pas vacciner ça veut dire c'est à cause
de toi si on porte des masses c'est à
cause de toi si on est confiné tu sais
ça veut dire qu un gouvernement a décidé
une société où tu a élu un gouvernement
qui a décidé que il faut
comparaison n'est pas raison mathieu
pour deux raisons ba précise d'abord que
j'ai pris une bonne raison n'est pas
viable comme la vaccination n'est pas
obligatoire mais rouler à 265 m y pala
interdit donc c'est une saison passée
sont obligatoires avait quasiment vu
passer de même
quelque chose les jeunes qui trompe avec
s'ils ne sont pas hors la loi attend de
mathieu excusez moi mais c'est le conte
de la vigne à turin n'est pas encore la
raison
il ya tout ici les gens choisir
ce n'est pas une addition
[Rires]
lui ça réduit on est pas médecin vous
êtes à peine chroniqueurs
oui il faut se faire vacciner non
taisez-vous non mais aux français par
arrêté
donc son annonce s'est faite sur les
réseaux sociaux ils répètent depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'il attendait le
bon moment et la bonne manière et il a
choisi les réseaux sociaux ce midi il a
publié une vidéo de 10 minutes et 11
secondes dans laquelle il se lance
officiellement dans la course à
l'élection présidentielle qui n'est plus
donc de réformer la france mais de la
sauver c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
j'ai donc décidé de solliciter vos
suffrages
le président de la république d'alors
donc cette vidéo il ya un petit souci
dans cette vidéo c'est que il ya des
images qui ont été prises un peu partout
dont des images de débris qui est là ce
soir il ya des images aussi le quotidien
qui pose problème puisqu'il ya un
problème de droit à l'image vous le
saviez s'est pas dit alors un point le
droit à l'image on le verra ce qui est
clair c'est que et un certain nombre de
droits qui ont été payées il y en a
d'autres qui relève de la courte
citation d'accord une jurisprudence ni
autorise à utiliser des très courts
passages sans dénaturer l'oeuvre sans
porter atteinte à qui ce soit moi je
suis persuadé que quiconque d'autre
aurait fait cette vidéo personne
n'aurait vu de problème sauf que là il
s'agit d'eric zemmour a effectivement
maintenant l'enjeu c'est il est candidat
il faut trouver les 500 signatures
on est entre 250 et 300 lors qu'il ya
220 manque encore un peu plus de ses
converse comptable joli très beau très
beau mais plus rapide que moi c'est
réussi est ce qu'il a réussi son entrée
en campagne karine pour moi c'est une
entrée qui à côté de la plaque
si on n'avait pas de la couleur on
aurait pensé que c'est une une
déclaration des années 50 général
de gaulle je trouve c'est d'une
arrogance extraordinaire
on a vu qu'à marseille il n'a pas pu
rencontrer est marseillais deuxième
ville de france quand même je vais dire
à un moment donné on s'enferme avec ses
militants je sais pas donc fait sa part
en bi laurine depuis quelques semaines à
campari zemmouri sa déclaration de
candidature à mon avis démontre qu'il
est dans il est dans un temps qui n'est
pas le nôtre celui du 21e siècle enfin
moment ses compagnes quelques jours
c'est pas parce que les autres vous ne
devez pas les autres scénaristes ce
n'est pas une pensée politique anodine
alors n'est pas un candidat comme les
ont arrêtés nous faire croire ça mais
vous pouvez le volet sur les plateaux de
télé vous vous voir les matches passent
et tous mais voilà le message qu'ils
sont sur les plateaux voulait empêcher
les membres à l'image des idées d'eric
zemmour
soit un ratio est quelqu'un est venu au
fascisme fait comme son goût que
promouvoir la haine
et un règlement de compte par écran
interposé celui de simon castaldi
candidats de télé-réalité et d'hervé
patrons de bars à chicha en vendée dont
l'âge ne poserait pas me contredire et
maloney
toi ton père ton grand père tu de ta
famille jetons
alors qu'il avait bouclé les
influenceurs pour une soirée samedi
dernier simon castaldi aurait empoché
l'argent sans jamais se présenter on se
donne rendez vous le samedi 27 pourquoi
il n'est pas venu à la soirée non
m'aider à partir du vendredi
plus de réponses
plus de réponses ok nous on a tout
acheté un nom s'est cassé le plus on a
fait la bouffe on en avait pris les
réservations on a tout fait samedi pas
de nouvelles et on l'appelle on
l'appelle j'ai envoyé tous les messages
j'ai scanné tous les messages j'ai fait
tout j'ai tout fait ok on sentait la
carotte les gens nous appellent en
lisant ben simon vient de faire une
vidéo il paraît que sa meuf 6h10 y
en a tant là vous avez fait une vidéo
ensuite pour vous plaindre ouais c'est
dans la salle ça s'énerve et du
comportement de simon parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont venus quand réservé que
pour sont venus exprès pour voir si moi
je vous ai fait là d'abord s'appelle
insulter des gens publiquement moi et
mon père traiter sa mère de plus tout ça
ça je vous dis franchement ça ne se fait
pas monsieur je ne fais pas après les
relances les messages que j'ai sur mon
téléphone vous le menacer c'est quoi ces
façons de faire vous créez ou à février
passant de fermeture à
17 points tu m'insultes mais toi tu
redescends je m'en fout de toi déjà pour
commencer et déjà je vais vous dire à
rester ici c'est aujourd'hui votre fils
il fait les marchés est furax et grâce à
qui c'est quand son public c'est pas
grave famille qu'est ce que quand les
gens quoi vous mettez dans la sauce
encore mais deux importants mais des
modes à la sauce je voulais prendre mon
père de sa mère et qui c'est quoi le
rapport il faut qu'on trouve le moyen
pour le court et le moyen de vendre a vu
que tout est fait sur les réseaux de
légende tels sont nos téléphones
portables insulté sa mère mon père et
moi je n'y suis pour rien monsieur on se
connaît non je vous ai escroqué non je
vous ai manqué de respect non après vous
le faites vous insulter mon père sa mère
et moi ça s'appelle ça va assure public
comme ça je vais porter plainte ensuite
vous le menacer et vous menacez donc je
vais reporté parce qu'il est maintenant
vous allez arrêter de poids de penser
qu'elle a nos socios c'est un déversoir
à merde var et qu'on peut tout dire et
d'univers toulouse
moi monsieur mcphee jouer l'armée je
suis pas mon fils est notre fils qui
voit la gueule à ses quatre fils kim a
peur tu n'y as tu vois là je m'en fou
qu'est ce que je m'en fou qu'est ce que
tu racontes là c'est dû à l'arrêt de
nous faire chier les tons faire se lever
les amarres avec quelques août et ben on
n'écoute pas je ne suis pas dans cette
histoire ni mon père ni moi ni sa mère à
tokyo tu ne manques pas loin du pays ni
à moi ni à trouver la mire à sa mère il
faut que l'argent il me semble il sombre
dans la rendu à samedi après midi qu'une
fois qu'ils aient le feu est-ce qu'il
l'a rendu cet après midi et ce qui l'a
rendu cet après midi est ce qui l'a
rendu oui ou non cet après midi ok donc
je me suis fait chier dessus j'ai rien
fait mon père est celle ci dessus il
arrêterait sa mère on traite de [ __ ]
c'est pas grave
l'histoire est réglé et on se fait de la
pub on vient à l'île des masses et sa
mère m'a insulté sur ce plateau et c'est
ça se comporter en tant que le mal est
fait avoir je peux avoir des alertes
google les mes potes qui habite qu'est
ce qui s'est passé ton fils avoir des
messages d'insultés moi sur mon
téléphone en disant des alliés monsieur
des répercussions à une femme moi j'ai
moi j'ai que ses quatre enfants j'ai pas
envie de me sied dans les bottes pour il
sort de boîte de nuit dont je me branler
monde entier mais on n'a pas le droit on
n'a pas le droit de faire en sorte que
la haine se déchaîne sur les autres et
parce que de monsieur ça a des
conséquences et un jour je vous le dis
faites pas t'es fait ça si vous voulez
mais un jour quand il y aura un drame
quand on aura quelqu'un qui sera qui
serait acquis qui sera frappé ou qui
sera but et on viendra sur le plateau
pour pleurer parce qu'ils étaient buté
et ce sera trop tard monsieur monsieur
sera trop tard et allgaier eu un drame
ce sera trop tard je n'ai rien à vous
dire je vous souhaite bon courage
d'aller battre avec votre jeu vous je
vous le souhaitez voir ses vrais fils
mémoire initiative mais très bien que
seulement 56 ans et lucas gibert des
gens si mon fils était peut-être qu'il a
peut-être qu'il a eu peur mais si mon
fils pas mal pour un coup de barre à
mine et que je le retrouve mort dans la
rue parce que vous avez déclenché la
haine chez moi de le voir
donc c'est vrai que pour tout le monde
comprenne bien cette affaire qui me
tient à coeur en va revoir ce qu'il
avait listé le 9 février 2010 8 me
rappelais plus est ses comptes regardez
moi je n'ai aucun problème avec agathe
comme je lui ai dit voilà moi je n'y a
aucun souci à agathe tu veux pas
[Applaudissements]
excuse non pardon est et les réfugiés au
début je connais bien jean comme ça ça
veut dire qu'ils aiment bruit c'est vrai
second degré dieu voilà alors non non si
j'avais désamorcer gentiment
voilà donc si tu savais même pas que
j'étais là en plus de gens là j'étais à
l'ouest ça va vous au niveau de mémoire
ce qu'on ferait pas pour
vraiment ces listes étaient sept
héritiers un acte de paix le match est
en guerre avec personne non mais est-ce
qu'on permet de traiter d' hystérique
quand même ça sinon j'ai dit bigard
lalanne et les autistes eric abadie
bigard est un hystérique hystérique
[Musique]
importe
c'est péjoratif
ensuite plutôt si à ce moment là alors
c'est pas pu de [ __ ] non il a dit plus
haut ça
cpg bien sûr mais c'est il faut remettre
les choses dans leur contexte et là
après lui c ils donneraient n'importe
quoi pour un bon mot et pour faire rire
alors je comprends que ça vous est
blessé d'ailleurs j'étais la première à
dire excuse toi la mapad vrai à l'époque
donc je vais pas faire floquer
aujourd'hui de laisser maintenant après
évidemment je n'ai rien contre vous
voilà entre jean marie beney après un
droit pas d'accord sur lui et ou d un
bar alors ça on l'a déjà dit vous avez
tout à fait le droit de mettre d'accord
avec lui après c'est vrai que la danse
dans son contexte c'est vrai que c'est
vulgaire et que voilà il a vraiment ça
pour faire rire voilà mais je pense que
là comme je vous l'avais dit ce jour là
vous avez du second degré je pense que
vous êtes intelligente et que vous savez
que c'est ma tatie venez vous voir en
moins sur le put quoi aucun temps il
faut remettre les choses dans leur
contexte mais moi par exemple ma
première télé j'étais pétrifiée c'était
michel drucker on venait pour une pièce
de théâtre bachy est là avec jean marc
eechaut milieu des 2 et drucker dire
alors comment vous vous êtes rencontrés
tous les deux et je n'aime pas le temps
d'ouvrir la bouche que ben sidi dans un
bar à [ __ ] et voilà et je sais que
c'est leur humour j'ai été élu en reste
et frau
genton
[Rires]
mais tout ça pour finir que c'est cette
école a pas d'animosité
et voyez c'est mon meilleur ami baffie
et franchement je me suis fait traiter
de [ __ ] a pas mal de fois par la
rémission n'a pas envie de le
fait pour vous dire que c'est leur
humour grivois c'est bien comme ça que
ça fonctionne
avec l'information qu'on a appris hier
soir une enquête préliminaire est
ouverte le 20 novembre dernier contre
pierre ménès pour agression sexuelle
selon plusieurs sources j'en ai dit
sportif aurait eu des gestes déplacés
son avocat hier nous a dit que c'était
complètement inventée de toutes pièces
cette affaire la victime n'a pas voulu
porter plainte mais le parquet de paris
a décidé d'ouvrir une enquête
préliminaire on va en parler dans un
instant avec guillaume genton qui a
toutes les infos hier son avocat me
disais vous affirmer qu'il a eu à sa
disposition des preuves que pierre ménès
n'a eu aucun geste déplacé il dit que
c'est un non événement et joue sur le
fait que c'était en public donc les
faits il se serait donc déroulé le 20
novembre lors de psg nantes pierre ménès
il était invité en loge non pas par le
psg mais par une entreprise privée donc
dans cette logique est plutôt un salon
il y avait une cinquantaine de personnes
cinq ou six hôtesses et lorsqu'il aurait
croisé une de ses hôtesses qui sont des
jeunes femmes souvent très joli il faut
le dire il l'aurait touché il aurait
touché le corps et les seins de manière
très furtive donc la victime présumée
elle a une trentaine d'années elle est
mère de famille elle se dit choquée par
ce qui s'est passé mais elle n'a pas
porté plainte pour le moment ce sont des
témoins de la scène qui ont prévenu la
police qui est donc en train d'enquêter
et la victime elle ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer victime présumée ne souhaite
pas s'exprimer pour le moment sur cette
affaire voilà d'accord vient alors et
après on a deux versions différentes sur
un autre qu'il y avait beaucoup de
personnes dans le salon juste c'était
pire mais n'est ce donc là il va au parc
des princes franchement c'est étonnant
donc après tout ce qui s'est passé
c'est un sens oui ça pose la question
vous avez moi je les crois au nez enfin
moi j'ai jamais vu de gestes déplacés
après c'est quelqu'un qui a un humour
particulier qui aime bien faire des
blagues qui a aussi du recul sur ce qui
lui est arrivé voilà donc on
moi j'ai jamais vu de gestes déplacés
mais j'ai déjà entendu faire des blagues
sur sa notamment je l'avais croisé à la
rentrée dans une loge voilà il faisait
des blagues sur la sphère après voilà de
là à dire qu'il veut des gestes déplacés
moi je ne les ai pas vus en revanche il
a beaucoup témoin j'ai eu le club j'ai
des gens qui partant du salon qui ont vu
ce geste voilà peut-être que lui encore
une fois il l'a pris comme non pas une
agression c'était considéré comme une
agression par la victime présumée mais
aussi par les gens qui étaient autour
donc c'est là où c'est un peu
problématique malheureusement ils filent
vers des affaires aujourd'hui le
ministère de la justice a donné des
consignes très strictes au parquet il
faut pas obligatoirement que quelqu'un
porte plainte dès qu'un signalement d'un
témoin ou comme dit guillaume qui va
dire j'ai vu ça à ce moment là il ya une
enquête ouverte et aucune présomption de
culpabilité bien sûr mais il ya un
signalement qui repose sur des faits qui
paraissent recueillis dans un témoignage
structuré et donc on ouvre une enquête
et ils vont entendre les deux parties
voilà comment ça se passe ça peut très
bien se terminer par une extinction de
la procédure d'accord
on connaît désormais bilal assadi en
représentation divine faisant la une du
magazine lgbt têtu sa vie représentée en
une une sorte de christ comprenez vous
le boycott de la sntf est ce qu'on peut
avoir la une à chaque fois derrière moi
merci françois billot de lochner
président de la fondation service public
vous vous êtes catholique
traditionaliste proche des mouvements
radicaux ces tunnels vous dérange
françois est bien en tant que catholique
je vais vous dire très franchement
ça ne me choque même pas d'accord et
vous savez pourquoi toi parce que je
trouve ça tellement stupide que c'est
pas choquant c'est à dire voyez vous je
crois que ce qui peut choquer ses
cantons on a la volonté de nuire
notamment par exemple aux catholiques à
très grands groupes de catholiques en
lait chaud quand par exemple le christ
sur la croix et une de charlie hebdo
elle vous dérange absolument voir plus
profondément à la halle et une jolie
hainaut sont d'une stupidité ahurissante
vraiment je ne comprends même pas qu'on
puisse défendre les une de charlie hebdo
celle là font pas rire du tout pardon
vous font pas rire à moi ils me font pas
rire du tout du tout du tout est là
voyez vous on aurait eu le christ en
croix par exemple là j'aurais dit c'est
vraiment c'est satanique cet odieux
c'est pervers c'est cette atroce là je
trouve ça débile parce que ça rime à
rien j'avais eu l'idée mais vous savez
c'est ça c'est simple c'est le
brainstorming
autour de la future une quand on fait
dans toutes les rédactions là c'était un
numéro de fin d'année effectivement on
avait décidé le nommé personnalité de
l'année donc en naviguant sur les thèmes
fin d'année on voulait l'installer comme
une icône est donc assez vite arriver
cette idée de la madone de l'icône
assure qu' un classique de la culture
pop madonna l'a fait bien de celle a
fait tout le monde l'a fait trop je
crois que c'était pas en plus le but je
pense pas que c'était dû choquer ah non
non bâti on a eu chaud au coeur
c'est ce que berné c'est pas choquant
franchement
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment transformé
bilal hassani ans ce costume dans cette
position et avec tout ce qui est de
sous-entendus derrière la symbolique
quand même oui mais pas passez votre
temps à expliquer qu'on est non je ne
vienne accusant son think and only dès
qu'on reprend l'imagerie qui est
parfaitement autorisé même par la
religion catholique criaient a dû
tourner en voir au blasphème qui encore
non mais si tu veux confusion je ne dis
pas que c'est tu me lâches schéma toi je
dis que ça entretient de mon point de
vue accord il ya peut-être des cats qui
vont trouver ce trait blasphématoire
têtu c'est formidable c'est magnifique
mais je suis désolé ça ne va pas de soi
d'exposer sa dans une gare dans une gare
vous avez plein de gens de tous les âges
de toutes les confessions de toutes les
origines en quoi ça sert mais laissez
moi finir qui circulent dans la gamme et
cette une il faut les expliciter je suis
désolé a des enfants et des jeunes il
faut leur dire ce que c'est et quand
vous êtes dans une gare où il avait
autre chose à faire que de dire ce que
c'est donc pour moi ça n'a rien à faire
dans une gare même si ces magnifiques
lacs aux eaux et forêts de la région
voyageurs
et oui pardon monsieur mais vive le
blasphème on a grand blasphème non si
vous mais ces messieurs pourtant la
drogue la salle droit oui on a bien sûr
le droit et c'est magnifique et je
m'insurge et je trouve ça scandaleux que
la sncf et la ratp et est interdite 7
disons que je ne sais même plus comme ça
qu'on revient aux quatre victimes si on
n'aime pas on ne regarde pas ben voilà
voilà voilà et moi je ferme les yeux
fermés les yeux maintenant le droit
pardonnez moi mais je m'en fous
complètement on est dans une notion qui
est vraiment une scion la grèce
humaniste intelligence de beaune est
restée si je suis désolé mais par
exemple dans les kiosques à journaux on
a des images pédopornographiques y sont
et allez on va dire aux enfants
attendait les enfants ne regardez pas
une image pédopornographique et sur le
kiosque à journaux
je suis totalement d'accord avec
monsieur il ya des images qui peuvent
choquer les enfants qu'on ne peux pas
expliciter parce qu'on voyage habitation
la nation parce que vous ne comprenez
vous le boycott de la sncf oui à 80%
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]